[Music]
before we get started i just wanted to
mention
for those unaware that i also have a
mythology channel where i post a couple
of times a week
if that's your thing then be sure to go
and check it out i'll leave a link to
the channel in the pinned comment
down below hey everyone welcome to
another installment of harry potter
theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing lavender brown
fenrir greyback the battle of hogwarts
and
werewolves more specifically we're going
to be discussing the fan theory
that lavender brown becomes a werewolf
i'll give you the theory first
then i'll provide you with my thoughts
first things first
what are werewolves werewolves are
considered to be a category
5x creature by the ministry of magic
meaning that they are
impossible to domesticate reason with
and equally dangerous to wizard kind
werewolves suffer from a condition
called lycanthropy
and it's this condition that forces them
to transform from a more human form
into their more violent wolf-like form
at the first sign of a full moon
while in their werewolf form werewolves
have no awareness of who they are
interacting with this means that even
the friends and allies of a werewolf
aren't safe during a full moon
furthermore when they revert back to
their regular form
they will have no recollection of the
terrible actions that they made
notable werewolves from the series
include remus lupin and fenrir greyback
however lupin contains his condition
somewhat with a
wolfsbane potion what's interesting
about fenrir however
that even his human form appears to be
mostly werewolf at this stage
unlike lupin who looks just like any
other wizard perhaps the most
unfortunate aspect of werewolves in
harry potter
is the stigma placed on them by the rest
of the wizarding world
werewolves are oppressed and the
majority of witches and wizards
look at them like scum they're diseased
and they have no place
in regular society lupin describes it
accurately
you've only ever seen me amongst the
order or under dumbledore's protection
at hogwarts
you don't know how most of the wizarding
world sees creatures like me
when they know of my affliction they can
barely talk to me
provided the werewolves are on the
receiving end of a considerable amount
of stigma and oppression
it shouldn't come as any surprise that
they've given that energy right back to
the wizarding world
in fact werewolves started a revolution
in which they sought power of their own
this meant infecting as many others with
lycanthropy as possible
turning regular witches and wizards into
werewolves themselves
so with that said was lavender brown one
of these casualties
did she become a werewolf the first
thing that needs to be considered when
it comes to this theory
is whether lavender brown is alive or
not the thing about lavender is that
it's never explicitly stated
that she's dead or alive after the
battle of hogwarts the book doesn't give
us that information
and the film suggests it but it isn't
confirmed
lavender is only presumed dead which is
what brings some level of validity to
the theory that
after being bitten by fenrir greyback
lavender became a werewolf
in order to become a werewolf you need
to get bitten by one
and lavender certainly was so is the
theory plausible
as it turns out there's one more
important ingredient that's required
in order for someone to be properly
infected with lycanthropy a full moon
per pottermore to become a werewolf it
is necessary to be bitten by a werewolf
in their wolfish form
at the time of the full moon when the
werewolf's saliva mingles with the
victim's blood
contamination will occur this raises
another question
was lavender bitten during a full moon
did the battle of hogwarts
occur during a full moon based on both
lupine and fenrir's untransformed state
during the battle
we should be able to quite easily deduce
but there was
in fact no full moon sure micasalupin
could have taken some wolf spain
but that only alleviates symptoms it
doesn't stop the transformation
furthermore i would imagine that
greyback would have embraced a
transformation during such an important
battle in conclusion
lavender brown did not become a werewolf
however
she very well may have survived and
that's it for this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe
to the channel until next time it is the
quality of one's convictions that
determine success
not the number of followers
you